[Music]
all right we're starting now
foreign
coming back at you with that the r r man
the r r with the Lords uh we had
dedicated an entire show to Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum how do they pronouncing
that
quantumania Quantum media yeah so we're
uh we'll get to that here in a minute
you know let's get to what we've been
watching here recently King what you've
been watching
um Last of Us uh I haven't seen that
episode yet
are you serious no I haven't because oh
my God so much stuff was going down this
week and uh I knew since we're doing the
spoiler cast we were doing them both in
one episode so I figured maybe it's best
to get them as close together
okay
yeah well I'm gonna tell you you don't
want to miss this one
I feel like this is that a good thing
yeah it's it's a good one it's a real
good one
what's going on
if we've been got a lot of stuff going
on guys
attic slacking no attic just got stuff
going on
nah you know this this has been a crazy
week it was it was a crazy week for me
too I'm surprised that I did get a
chance to uh do all the stuff that I did
watch I watched the bad batch because
tonight I have a episode of um
or what is it uh the Lord's minute
that's on uh
um Lords of gaming.net uh you can check
that out uh we're going to delve deep
into uh the last two episodes of um the
bad batch if you're watching this on
Disney plus uh it's it's an incredible
uh last two episodes you have the Clone
conspiracy and uh what was the next one
oh the next one was truth and
consequences so you gotta check that out
um I'll be doing that right after I do
this and that's only on the website so
you got to go to the website and check
that out
probably have some um some links on
Twitter if you follow me I've actually
been finishing up on
the last season of Better Call Saul
oh for real I never saw any episodes
that I did uh used to watch Breaking Bad
yeah that's probably yeah the only show
that came close to beat and Breaking Bad
is my favorite show of all time was Game
of Thrones but you know they didn't end
it they didn't kind of lost you with the
with the ending me for me Breaking Bad
turned into a crazy phenomena I don't
know when I jumped it I probably jumped
in when it was like three seasons in and
then I just jumped in and
um Heisenberg uh basically took over my
life for a long period of time I'm at
Jesse downtown you know while I was
working and stuff like that because you
know my my former uh company used to put
me in contact with a lot of stars and
celebrities or whatever you want to call
them so yeah I met Jesse and uh he's a
little eccentric a little eccentric yeah
what I've been told he he's how he is in
the Breaking Bad show like oh no he's
he's nothing like the voice yeah yeah
yeah he's he's he's very very uh uh what
can I say um
open out there uh
yeah he's he's he's he's he's uh what is
he
yeah I guess that's the term he's he's
out he's out so did you get a chance to
catch up here on you
uh no didn't watch any episodes of you
didn't watch any episodes of Attack on
Titan because remember my episodes of
Attack on Titan that's not has nothing
to do with you that has everything to do
with me uh my episodes Attack on Titan
is on the patreon live reaction so you
know I'm really holding a progress in my
house because you know my wife likes to
watch it so um
all right so you know I guess what we'll
be doing is we'll go ahead and move
straight on to uh the the businessman
the business we both went and watched
Ant-Man and you know obviously I want to
keep a good portion of this probably
about 30 minutes
non-spoiler and then we'll go into you
know spoiler territory and then I want
to talk about whether or not
Ant-Man is a step in the right direction
and the the MCU especially with like DC
picking things up that's all I want to
talk about you know the competition
they're going especially going into
Ant-Man uh so first off uh we haven't
talked chat about ain't mad at all no I
I've purposely avoided this dude
yeah so we haven't talked about Ant-Man
at all and you know we're gonna we're
gonna really break it out king but what
what what's your overall perspective on
not only Ant-Man in general but this
game this movie being the first movie in
their um in their phase five
well definitely well this this is a
Shameless plug I like to plug uh stuff
that I use that I respect I'm not
getting sponsored by these dudes at all
hopefully attic and I can get sponsored
by them at some point in time but um
Regal unlimited uh I'm not gonna lie uh
this thing is uh fantastic I think uh
this Friday I'm gonna go get my wife her
own Regal unlimited because there's so
many movies that's going to be coming
out throughout the year and you get a
chance to go to all the movies that you
want to see unlimited amount of times so
I'm getting her her own on unlimited and
you know have my own unlimited and you
know we go to the movies every week or
whatever it enhances date night uh it
lessens the burden or in the pocket what
you got to do is just come up with some
food and you get a couple of um you know
free items and stuff like that uh and
also it's like it's like Game Pass be
honest with you so you know I'm addicted
to these services so
now my overall uh views of um Ant-Man
this movie in in in general or the
character and the world that they
crafted in this movie what do you mean
uh so first off let's just go over the
oh the overall perspective of the movie
you know what what your expectations
were going into it and what ultimately
ended up uh didn't meet your
expectations did it not then we'll go
into individual world the world that
they built is the first time we were in
this certain area like for this amount
of time seeing this civilization and you
know just the overall characters came
you know was Ant-Man uh it just will go
we got we got a show man we got a line
let's first off let's talk about
expectations in the actual Ant-Man movie
well my expectations were shot from the
beginning because this is supposed to be
the um microverse not the quantum
Universe right uh they don't have the
rights to say micronauts microverse I
believe that's owned by Hasbro
um so we won't get a lot of the
characters that is supposed to be tied
to this world this uh
this world is Barren
um in the beginning when we go get uh
Jane Van Dyne
and uh apparently it's not now
apparently it's a whole universe within
itself apparently we have the whole Star
Wars Universe with law and stuff like
that that's there
the problem is
you have a bunch of formerly a-rated uh
uh a-listed actors with Michelle
Pfeiffer and um
Michael Douglas and then you have uh
Paul Rudd he's not a leading man
um
in in in movies so you have a bunch of
cat uh actors that are you know BT
characters and there's nobody there with
the star power and the gravitas to pull
off a movie that's ushering us into
phase five I think this was a poor
selection
going into phase five I think the World
building was poor I thought the law
around it was poor there was nobody for
you to care about the only person that
you did care about was Jonathan Mages
and he's the villain right he's the only
one that had the star power I feel like
the only other person that gravitated
towards you was the weird green thing
like and that was all like and and he
didn't even do it but I felt like out of
everyone
that's the only thing I felt like they
actually gave character behind like it
was like I got holes like oh you're
talking about the the well um on my
screen it was like pink orange thing the
jelly thing but see that's a Disney
Trope Disney always give you some
lovable character for you to say oh my
god
um I'm in love with this character and
he's so hilarious and he's so funny and
I I want to know more about this
character to sell more uh Toys you know
um
ah boy this this one was a hard one to
swallow uh pause because
you have to look at the first of all
let's let's start with the fundamentally
broken character himself Scott Lang
right Scott Lang is Ant-Man in the book
Scott Lang wasn't Ant-Man for longer
than the time that he stole the suit
right he stole a suit and uh Hank Pym
got him and I don't know why they did
this Dynamics you know hope Van Dyne is
not the WASP okay so it's Jane Van Dyne
and it's then they never had a kid all
right that's why Ultron was born
um but you you have Hank Pym Jane Van
Dyne that's Ant-Man that's the WASP
right uh Scott Lang and hope never
happened uh that was never a thing uh
the fact that they're making our male
characters weaker uh
this Ant-Man Scott Lang has no powers
over ants
like your your main thing uh opposed to
what the WASP does the WASP flies and
she has stings Ant-Man is supposed to
control an army of ants you don't
control Army of anything you just get
small and get large and then in the
books you don't have that power to go
from large and small no it's either you
giant man or your Ant-Man one of the two
that's it and they showed a psychotic
break inside the books that if he was
doing the giant man and Ant-Man thing at
the same time he was going to have a
mental break he was going to turn into
yellow jacket I I.E yellow jacket in
this uh universe is now uh um what's
this guy that um moduk
Morocco what
like you know modic was made from
Advanced uh idea mechanics aim right and
then he ended up like taking over aim
two yes that's my biggest thing is how
they handled that character but we'll
get into that later it's it's I mean
it's just a cost of buck to be honest
with you of a film The the I I thought
everything I mean um
myself for Jonathan Mages
was just like what
are you kidding me you know the majority
of the film
is characters acting out of place
uh
not you know stepping up to their
potential too much unheard of backstory
so now
Jane the WASP Jane Van Dyne is there for
30 years but she's having illicit
affairs
with all these random uh micro uh
individuals
I'm like what while while her husband uh
Hank Pym is trying to get her out of the
quantum realm I'm like what and this is
just so complicit and so blase as they
talk about it as she's falling over the
dude that she was messing around with
for 30 years with her husband that she
was married to for that same 30 years at
the same restaurant which is ridiculous
it's it's a farce of a movie to be
honest with you it's a farceable movie
so it's safe to say this movie didn't
meet your expectations what it it was it
didn't even shoot close to my
expectations you know the fact of the
matter is make Ant-Man control his ants
right why why is Hank pimp stepping up
why why is Hank pimp stepping up with
with the the end control was it Hank
Penman Avenger
no see this is this is the craziest part
about it I mean in the book season of
Avenger that's what I mean in the books
in the books he's Ant-Man this there's
no Scott Lang you know I mean Scott Lang
is there for probably one episode I mean
one one comic book when he steals uh he
finds uh Hank pym's uh Ant-Man armor and
Pen particles and he steals it and that
was it he's just a very clever Thief
stole it that's about it and off to the
next but it has really nothing to do
with this guy and and I don't know why
Marvel chose to write a whole world or
synopsis around the Thief character who
is not that bright
he's not that bright and Hank Pym is
probably one of the brightest Minds in
the Marvel Universe it that comes he
comes up he came up with pen particles
this dude don't know how pen particle
work all he knows is how to get small
and how to get big literally he just
knows how to use a suit that's all he
knows how to press a button on her suit
if something happens to the suit he
can't make a suit
come on man
so all right now now that we've uh
talked about you know the expectations
here's how I felt about it
I just
I think Kang was so underutilized in
this movie and like stuff didn't make
sense sometimes I felt like he was
living this potential and then sometimes
it didn't make sense of what was going
on I also feel like
the story behind what happened 30 years
didn't make sense to why things are
going on the way it is like ironically
she goes with them you know what I'm
saying like yeah it just it felt like a
lot of coincidence too much coincidence
here coincidence there and you know
let's get back to the let's get to the
world
I did like the world I felt like the
world was built well
but there were certain mechanics in it
that you know Kane is clearly in charge
of this world you know I I do like how
you know they kind of give you the bait
and switch
where uh she's like well I'm gonna go
see a friend and they show you that
scene at the beginning where she's
meeting King yeah you think it's them
you know what I'm saying like
so you know
all I want to say is the world that they
built in here was very unique
it's just everything in it didn't work
out
well the the world you know what it felt
like it felt like Star Wars light
right it did if you remember at the end
what the the big thing comes through it
kind of felt like a walker you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah like an attic
it's it's
you know this Disney man
you're running out of stuff because
this world could have been so
much better right the the reason why I
said it okay so we have Guardians of the
Galaxy and we pretty much have
established parameters when it comes to
the space stuff right uh they on um
nowhere uh nowhere is uh head of a
Celestial where they harvest the brain
matter uh as far as currency and stuff
like that goes all right good good and
everything that spawns from there you
have uh the Nova Corps which is the
police you have the cree okay we know
where the cree are and we have the
Scrolls we know where the scrolls are it
is kind of crazy how well that movie
branched out into the actual MCU right
and this movie did it a little bit but
it's just like none of these characters
were memorable like none of them some of
them are okay that's cool but it's like
none of them I was like I want to see
them in a movie or they have their own
movie all of them was like okay thank
God that we're done why did you hear
about any of them
no I didn't so do you didn't care about
the world ending or not so that was the
whole thing that when Kang was saying it
makes no sense he said you can go to
your family now I won't mess with your
timeline
made no sense yeah
that's King the Conqueror that's what
I'm saying that's not Kane like okay the
way I've been told King's mentality is
he's deceitful and if anything is going
to mess with his reality and what he
envisions the future it doesn't matter
what he says he's getting you up out of
there well he would he would have sent a
home it was it was it was two different
things he would have done
that regardless to what his goal was
something else to be honest with you and
we're going to get to that part but his
goals was something else we have 31
watch and we only have 20 likes wipe
your feet before you come inside this
house I'm really pissed off and if you
want all the energy please hit that like
button
um share it out let everybody know
what's going on it's um
I'm disgruntled I'm disgruntled I'm
disgruntled in the portrayal of uh some
of the characters uh I'm disgruntled in
in the world building the World building
and Kang himself he's an honorable man
honorable man but he's a man for his own
means right so his own means was to get
what was lost
right and Scott Lang was only person
that was able to do it or the only
person dumb enough to go get it for him
and I guess that's the only reason why
you you have this guy play Ant-Man
because he's dumb enough to go get Kang
something that he wants because Hank Pym
wouldn't have been dumb enough to go get
it and if you
what the daughter even do in this movie
like it was false feeding us would the
daughter even realistically okay let's
just get to spoiler guys like
get to it because who Miley Cyrus
I don't know who that was it
looked the biggest issue I had in this
movie was how they portrayed Kane and
early on they made you think he was this
force to be reckoned with he is and I
get it huh he is okay and I get it there
was a lot of ants
they there's a point in the movie
where there's a bunch of ants that are
attacking Kane to me
those ants should have been swarming
them but not doing any damage
because to me
those ants don't
far sin his technology you know what I'm
saying like you mean to tell he he's
getting hit by countless things in this
movie
and nothing's damaging but some ants are
able to like destroy half his armor you
know what I'm saying like it made no
sense how this was going down I could I
can I can give you a push back off of
that right we know in the Ant World what
ants do is they overwhelm
right and and they keep chipping away
until they can actually find a weakness
and they and they did find a weakness
and it was one ant that used a certain
uh weapon that they invented remember
this Tech ants were making this Tech and
they were there for thousands of years
right uh so you know Hank said when it
was falling down into the rabbit hole so
thousands of years they uh elevated and
uh grew that the tech that they had when
they went into the world so the
evolution of the text should be on par
with whatever King was using because at
that period of time King is using future
Tech from the year what is it uh 30 35
something like that that armor is from
that far so they were very Advanced
these ants were so they would tell you
it's just like the stuff they that they
were attacking them with like the you
know they had like the little beam stuff
and like the little kind of like
lightsaber uh yeah think about it but to
me
they hell oh fairs like I said this
movie was great Paris you should have
been here in Paris would you like to
join sir
uh we're gonna have to disagree with you
on that one Paris I mean I would love to
get your rebuttal here
it's just I think to me when it comes to
this movie
is I'm just like I expected more from
from King and it's not the actor the
actor did fantastic I expect a better
writing for him what'd you mean to build
up to him yeah I just
I didn't get it I like you know I I I
did I liked his Persona at the beginning
but I felt like at the end like this man
has been trying to get out of the
quantumanium whatever they want to call
it for thousands of years or whatever it
is 30 years and 30 plus years look he
had the opportunity to leave but instead
he went over there started hitting
Ant-Man over and over again like to me
Pac-Man right here right and you see
those little antennae those little
antennae
talk to ants right talk to ants
I have ants over there have a giant
Ant-Man and have this little one this
one comes with XM Studios
um
hell are you going to have an Ant-Man
movie
where he controls no ants
yeah it took to me
I think the the biggest thing I just
wanted is I wanted I wanted just someone
because obviously this is going to be
the new Thanos of this Saga oh he's he's
going to definitely but but to me this
is one of the first portrays of him
besides that you know little bit in Loki
where I expected to see this man shine
and I and I thought I thought he shied
to certain parts of the movie
but you mean Thanos let's take Thanos
Thanos for Iron Man Spider-Man all the
Guardians of the Galaxy all at once and
this man couldn't take a Hitman well so
but you see what I'm saying like people
people have been hype in this individual
like he's this but this dude to be
reckoned with and then when I actually
see him he gets took out by ants and he
gets and he can't take on Ant-Man in a
one-on-one fight
he was beating the brakes off of Paul
rush
I feel you but King came in and saved
him she he was beat he but like I said
Thanos
yeah but okay so you're talking about
the McGuffin for the movie we got to go
how to direct this one to go how the
directors want to take us right it's the
same thing with the writers in comic
books we can always have this should
have been done this way or this should
have been done that way but it's always
ultimately up to the writers and the
writers wanted to give you that tension
where uh Paul Rudd was he going to live
was he going to die was he going to be
stranded here what was he going to do
was he willing to sacrifice and give up
more of himself in order to beat king
and like you said you know
um I don't have to beat you
I just have to make sure none of us went
and shout out to how they at the end
they make you feel like okay they
defeated Kane but they can't go back and
then they're just sitting there and then
the the portal just opens right behind
me but remember she she she built the uh
the triangle uh ability and for the
beacon
in order to go down there and to
retrieve so she already had these
signatures built into the computer and
she was able to triangulate and and
Paris said king without Tech he is a
normal man like Iron Man this King here
was one of the worst ones then why did
he get banished by the best ones
okay he got banished because that's King
the Conqueror he's the one incites uh
excuse me he incites the violence he
incites the riot he he he wants to be
head of the tribunal I couldn't even
believe that they were they did the
tribunal of Kings
that that was that within itself was uh
talk about the end scene the end yeah
that was cool I like that see I know
where they're going with that I do it's
just to me as a non comic book reader
that don't know anything just to face
value of Kane he's seeing he seems like
one of the worst villains ever in MCU at
the moment well you wanted like an
inform of power and form a threat he
just seems like one of the worst well
the threat is is real he kills Avengers
he he killed it like how he was like he
was like I'm an Avenger he was like well
which Avenger are he's like I've killed
so many are you the one with the hammer
yeah like yeah blending uh over a period
of time it's
it's it he's he's really everything that
you that you think that he's supposed to
be right
Kang is a man the armor and attack the
future check that he does have and that
uh machine his chronological machine
that machine allows him to be who he is
so you know so without that Tech he is
just a normal man
so I think this is where my disconnect
is personally right is keep in mind I
don't the only time I know anything
about comic book stuff is if I look up a
video because King told me to brush up
on a character right
first first
thoughts of Thanos uh you saw him in the
ship fighting uh fighting the Hulk that
was like that that wasn't the first time
you saw him but that was the first real
time you saw him yeah but he had the
power Stone he wasn't using it he fought
him one
but he's also a Titan I I know but I'm
not referring to this or that I'm
referring to just face value right when
you see Thanos for the first time you
show how dominant he is he's sitting
there taking on uh the Hulk one-on-one
he could have easily jumped the Hulk but
Dennis is like nah I'ma fight this dude
one-on-one and like and that was the
first time we seen that man the first
time we've seen this dude it's just like
I like certain moments with him like
when they were in those prisons and he
was using his powers I thought why'd he
use that like the whole movie after that
well his armor was broken
I still can't get on with the ants
breaking that armor I don't know why I
can't I can't jump on that thousands of
times thousands of years to advance the
tech like you're looking at them as
simple ants they're highly intelligent
they would they didn't even look like
the ants that went in remember at that
point for a period of time
that there were thousands of them and
they got his armor off why did they kill
him
he got away from him he's that strong
well so he was able to get away from
them yeah but he was he was getting back
to his machine to you listen I didn't
write the script that's why I told you
I'm telling you it's principal I'm
telling you from a fan perspective
it's a pissport script I'm sorry it
could have been a thousand times better
but they they failed to they they keep
on with these movements these if this is
the start of a phase five then scrap the
whole phase five because it's just like
phase four I still have hope for MCU I
know a lot of people are down on MC
right now I I think this movie could
look in the overall sensation to this
going into other you know MC projects to
The Avengers they did a good job showing
Kang as a threat at the end with you
know his little uh get together thing I
don't know you call you it said you said
it had a name on it I didn't catch it
yeah you called the columns it's called
the Council of Kings the council
that single scene so okay King isn't an
issue because of one individual he's an
issue because the whole conglomerate
together
when they work together see they have
worked together to get him out they have
worked together to to manage him to to
the quantum realm and they successfully
got him
and do you think they'll free this dude
because I don't think he's dead
he's not there yeah is this supposed to
be the king
that ends up being the biggest issue in
the end
okay so you thought he was supposed to
be the one who remains the one that was
lucky that's not him that's why the one
who remained said oh my next variant
that one
because he knows about rummitut that was
the Egyptian looking run he knows about
the scholar Centurion that was the blue
one I don't know why he was blue he's
supposed to be red okay um and he knows
about immortus all right though so those
three are
um
those three are the head of the council
and the rest of the kings that you saw
there Kings from different uh timelines
and different possibilities all there
that happened in the book I forgot what
I think it was Avengers or
Avengers something 128 okay then explain
to me the difference between why some
canes look identical and some look
Egyptian and some look like a cyborg
like
is it like pretty much a thousand Kings
going in one life and just some makes
decisions that they make so when um I
forgot his original name uh well when
Kane goes back in time he goes back when
he first gets attacked he goes back to
Egypt ancient Egypt times and he goes
there and he rules over them as a
pharaoh as Rama Tut and Fantastic Four
uh comes and outs him so maybe we'll get
that at that timeline and that fight
with the Fantastic Four versus romantic
then you have uh the Scarlets and
cheerion
um that came about I think after like a
Doctor Doom uh situation Dr Doom had him
like um disguise himself as a Scarlet
Centurion that was the guy that was in
the blue with his skin pulled back that
looked like
um uh RoboCop
from the three let me actually I will
bring it I'm sure there's a picture of
all three of them all right and then
immortus immortus is like the
the last king now he's not the last that
remains but he's the last king the most
you say the eldest King the one who who
tries to manipulate the most he's the
most conniving uh he he's he's he's a
good King in his different timelines
that you can actually get a chance to
see these like in Kang Dynasty in these
books uh but
for the most part
King will keep coming at you with
different Tech and he will definitely
um overtake you at some point in time
because he understands how the future
will go
now I know you're gonna say why he
didn't know about
um the ants
he didn't know about the ants because
all those stuff turns into variables and
started breaking off into different
paths and different uh timelines so
inevitably it started a whole different
timeline
because he probably had a timeline when
he got out of there
uh no it's actually hard to find what
was the uh the Egyptians name uh
rheumatoid
want me to to Google it up yeah go ahead
because I'm having a hard time finding
all right I'll do it I
let me feel you I do and I know that
this is just one of those things where
it's like
I got I gotta have faith in the in the
end thing you know how they make these
characters in the in the end but like to
me as just watching the Marvel aspect of
it it's just not looking good like I'm
not saying it's not gonna be good I'm
just saying from a perspective of seeing
Kang on screen for the first time I
expected like a similar to better
experience when I first saw Thanos
because because people told me that this
dude is way more of an issue than Thanos
but to me I didn't I didn't get that
like I really didn't get you know he
he's a huge issue
I got
Ant-Man
and Walsh could take this dude on like
that's what I well with broken armor
and now when we first came down he
walked down and he was zapping people
out of existence if they would have
showed up when he was zapping people out
of existence before those aunts showed
up
they would have they wouldn't have stood
a chance I feel you but to me breaking
his armor in the very first time you see
him is not a good look either no it's it
it's definitely not they he I personally
felt like this man should have had full
reign in this movie like and then what
happens
huh it just know then what happened you
could even have a a scenario where they
get out and he slept in the corner realm
but you know he's that strong you know
what I'm saying but to me you saw him
show a little bit of his strength and
then he ended up fighting people on that
thing and the Ants just took him out
took all of his powers like all right so
and then from then on you don't really
see anything going on after that I got a
question they left him down there the
ants are still in charge right well the
answer is well helping the world down
there and he's still down there right
and then we're going to find out how
he's going to get free
because we got to watch Loki
when he gets out because remember his
whole goal was to get revenge on the
council
I'm I'm getting the council that's all
he won he did not care about anything
else
what do you think
his thoughts is going to be right now
on Ant-Man because I was expecting
Ant-Man to die I I don't like Scott Lang
right so yeah his stories come out too
too happy ever after like I feel like
there's got to be sometimes P sometimes
bad stuff happens like it's just how it
is like yeah I mean I mean if they're
gonna do it then do it I I was expecting
him to die I was expecting his daughter
because they're pushing you in that
direction that his daughter actually
takes over the mantle because he no
longer has the guts to to be Ant-Man he
no longer wants to fight for the week
like he said let's write a book
you know he wants to sit down on his
Laurels so I expected I I I expected him
to die I I don't think
Disney didn't have the balls to pull off
a Ant-Man movie if you have a bunch of
b-rated actors
and you want an a tear
AAA movie
then you're gonna have to go for the
Gusto at some point in time and don't
rely on your big bad with this Jonathan
major Jonathan Majors needed a
protagonist that was equal on equal
footing for him to lose to and that
wasn't it and that's what you're having
a hard time to deal with because how the
hell is Ant-Man beating the next Thanos
and I I'm with you it's not even like
remotely on that it's like I get it you
know hand to hand
Le uh that King was was giving him that
work but to me if it like Ant-Man was
sitting there fighting Thanos
and wash showed up ain't stopping
nothing you know what I'm saying like
and I get it they they they disarmed him
but at the same time you've shown people
like me oh this dude ain't known without
that suit okay he he he he he lame
without that suit okay like I was like
this is not a good first impression of
power
you build up this entity to be this
Almighty to be the dude that that
overtook the rest the one that was so
strong that he was banished because
that's the way that they were making it
seem in this movie
but then
some ants took him out and Ant-Man and
wasp took him out okay so listen y'all
don't don't listen to at it cause attic
is going to tell you some ants took him
out like some regular Street ants
jumped on top of him and had some cookie
cutters and and got rid of them
um and yeah I feel you killing Brown
Doom should have been next yeah doom
doom is in there because where King lies
Dune High I have a feeling if they would
have had the Fantastic Four
uh property sooner they probably would
have had Doom I think this is all they
like to do stuff but they don't have
access to to those properties at that
time I don't think I don't I don't think
I don't think
they want to do
them in this cycle in this phase five
until they out of this cycle
and and they get to the Fantastic Four
and the Fantastic Fantastic Four has
been initiated
um because I think they want to do Doom
world I think they want to do battle
world I think they want to Branch off in
that area and have guard tear Doom like
I got over there
um
so no uh and doom is not someone that
you do lately the same way with Kang
you guys might be down on Kang right now
and and it's not no regular ants that
took him out okay so these are ants that
had thousands of years of evolution with
tech that they went inside the world
with and they uh evolved this Tech and
they use that Tech to attack and just
imagine ants with the tech of of Jedis
and Storm Troopers and they're running
inside your house that that's exactly
what it was
that makes sense but at the same time
the only thing we've only really saw
Kang do in this movie besides that first
thing is
defend himself from the ants
beat up Ant-Man for two minutes
and was an Ant-Man own this man that's
all we saw almost the entire movie
I mean I can't fight you because I don't
like the movie it's like it's like it's
like that gif where that dude's throwing
the elves like
listen I think the whole movie is now
that's just my opinion of it uh
I'm having a hard time dealing with it
because my expectations for the film was
so much better I thought they were going
to finally allow him to be who he's
supposed to be and not this uh
just just just just just stay to the
fundamentals of the law of of what is
written stay to the fundamentals man
Ant-Man is Ant-Man he's not giant man
giant man is a totally different
character uh within that whole persona
but again you cannot
go from Big to small to it's a wear and
tear on the body it's a psychological
Destroyer so why don't we stick to the
script didn't you love how like the
daughter had her suit for like half a
movie you learned how to become and just
showed it and didn't know how to use it
excuse me it was just
I don't like them pushing characters on
you they've they've done this they could
have had a a Disney plus series showing
her doing something way before this
happened
they could have they could have explored
her they could have made you care about
this character you did not care about
her I did not care about Paul Rudd I did
not care about hope
I did not care about any of them
no and one do what I did care about was
Hank and I'm like man they doing Hank
real dirty but Hank had his his
Redemption you know in this because Hank
is probably the smartest person next to
Reed Richards Tony Stark and Spider-Man
in this universe and Amadeus Cho
come on man all right so
let's get to let's get the nitty and
greedy
let's talk about
MCU
and the condition that the franchise is
in after this movie do you think it
improved it got worse or do you think
you know the ending is going to justify
the beginning and it didn't really move
the needle but it didn't move it down
either and it didn't help so how do you
feel about the MCU in general
the depiction of Cain
was incredible
right the depiction the armor the
regalness his uh arrogance
uh
the depiction of Modoc
was spot on I didn't it I'm so happy
they didn't run away
from making a screen accurate Modoc I
think the only thing I didn't like about
Modoc is like the character development
was kind of weird like he he's bad all
this movie and then he has one
conversation with the daughter and now
he wants to be good like like it takes
more than one conversation unless you're
Naruto to convince someone to not be bad
likes and how she did it it was just so
stupid it was
that's so stupid
um
I just kept waiting for her to break out
uh into a song it's breaking like like a
wrecking ball looking like mice I was
just so over it
um
the MCU is always in good hands
because they always have the literature
to fall back on they can always run back
to the paperwork to ride the ship they
can get sick and tired of a director's
trying to hand at this hey Kev I have an
idea and uh how about this you know I I
don't want the how about this director
going up into the office anymore
so I have high hopes for Guardians of
the Galaxy
that's uh you know James Gunn's last
film in Marvel so I think it's going to
be his cellular experience
do you think that the Golden Days the
MCU might be over no
what it is is you're seeing characters
get old
and this is the fair when you lock these
people in for years and you watch them
grow old I mean I saw
you know Paul Rudd old I saw the the
actress of uh that plays uh hope Van
Dyke old
um
nobody wants to see a a 50 year old
Spider-Man swinging up in in there
that's why they always you know cast new
cast new cast new so
they have to
re-cycle the actors and actresses they
have to do it they have to do it going
forward they have to get back to uh
Leading Men and leading women they have
to go back to that that stuff is very
fundamental and very necessary uh if
you're going to build somebody up if
you're going to go into World building
they could have did Small World building
very simple the quantum world and we
could have got that in Disney plus they
didn't do that they didn't they didn't
care enough to do that but no I got Mia
and the devil dinosaur on a Disney Plus
you could have took taken the time
to give us enough backstory and enough
good uh material to work with going into
this film because this two and a half
hour film
did not fill in the gaps that are is
it's too many holes
too many holes pause and what the little
guy said no I got holes now I can do
this
um it's just
uh is is it is the golden years passed
no they do have great stories that they
can tell they can def definitely 100 go
to the source material and give you good
material going forward I think one of
the biggest issues that you know we're
having in general is
this is New Territory for Marvel
to rebuild the universe after they did
the climax of The Thanos Saga so you
know at least at the beginning it was
fresh
when you're seeing Iron Man Thor Captain
America you know all these characters
interested in the MCU it was fresh we
never seen something like that but now
since the Thanos saga's over and they're
rebuilding that same infrastructure
we've seen it before already so it's
just like we're comparing this person of
Iron Man this person to Thor and it's
just I don't think that their character
is not necessarily are not hitting it's
just we haven't had enough screen time
and enough character development because
we can't compare
movie for Scotland we we can't compare
these movies
to in-game in in the infinity War
I see a lot of people are doing that
like they're comparing the top
of all of MCU to the newer stuff and
it's like look like it's going to be
hard for them to to come across and win
that and I think it's like I said it's
you know there might be a little bit of
MCU fatigue going on I I don't
necessarily believe that I think if you
always make something good people are
always going to enjoy it do you think
that is good
this one isn't good no thank you I mean
I mean a good movie is going to stand on
its own twos and this was not a good
movie and I think that's the biggest
issue is you're rebuilding new people to
take over the old people
and the only person you really have
that's like from that original original
group at this point I would say it's
like Doctor Strange
this movie was decent yeah I actually
think this movie's worse
than than uh than Dr Strange man it is
it is and I thought that movie was
horrible like it is and it sucks so bad
it's just
phase five is off to a rocky start
Guardians should uh hopefully fix it
okay because all right what you always
want in every MCU movie is for them to
introduce at least three characters
right so okay this is this is Kane's
first screen debut big screen debut
because we're not gonna count the Loki
series because if you didn't watch the
Loki series you don't know anything
about Kang right all right so
the introduced Kang they introduced
Modoc and they introduced uh Scott
Lang's daughter
uh Cassie
as a potential to be the new Ant-Man
giant man or whatever and he was low-key
training her during the movie right
because he was teaching McMahon because
you saw what she did and he was like
come on man did you see what I did you
see how I knew it you know you click and
pop you click and pop so we did get the
three characters right
now
King is definitely going to span across
a a larger
role inside everything will she play a
large role as far you know Cassie would
she play a large role and Modoc has to
have a revamping because he's not dead
right
um something is going to happen he has
to get back to his form he has to get
back to control moduk is a b tear
villain and
he was handled Like a f-tier Villain
right so he's a b-tier villain and they
they really need to just get back to his
core
um I think modic was mishandled King I
thought was handled properly uh from
introduction to Persona to clothe into
everything
and Cassie was handled
uh a little weak but we we when we get
the Young Avengers we should see a
little bit more uh from that character
I honestly feel that a better script
could have been written I wanted to see
more of the um Quantum verse
why is all these Indian Windows about
Jane van dyne's time in the quantum
Realm
uh you know all the time that she spent
with Kang
and then all the time that she spend
with the governor dude uh what's going
on here then why are there buildings
alive you know is it organic matter that
they live in
so many different plot holes that was
open and these stuff could have been
easily filled with uh junkets and
different uh short films that they could
have dropped in Disney plus this movie
needed a support and it didn't get the
support uh and and yeah they're gonna do
Young Avengers so you can sit there and
think they're not going to do Young
Avengers you're going to get a young
version of King the Conqueror in um that
Iron Man suit you're going to get Wiccan
and and and
um the Scarlet Witch kids you're going
to get uh what is it that the hawkling
you're going to get
um at uh Cassie as Ant-Man all of it is
setting up if if you just open your eyes
and see they're setting up Young
Avengers Young Avengers is coming
do you I got a question do you think
it's gonna be old
do you think that with this Flash and
James gone over there and looks like
he's setting a lot of right things do
you think that if those movies start
being successful MCU might change things
up or do you think they even care what's
going over there
it was funny is this is ironic
James Gunn is King the Conqueror they
banished him over there to the quantum
verse and he's going to build the
quantum first he's gonna build an army
after this Flash Film is out and and
Shazam is done that Blue Beetle is going
to tell you exactly who this man is
and honestly if he can make some Beetle
hit
they're in trouble
because
like it or not
DC has more iconic characters than
Marvel
because they have gods
hold on Hollywood rules with the two
dollar Super Chat King agree no more
directives going off the Brent yeah I'm
I'm with you no more directors
doing their own thing how about this
well perhaps we should try this I'm with
you I'm with you Hollywood and thank you
Chad I appreciate it do you think Kane
would have been a better villain
if you like he would have been showing
better if he was in a proper setting
like maybe a doctor strange movie or
something like an Avenger that has a
little bit more umph to him than a
Ant-Man no I think this was perfect I
think that just showed you the Council
of Kings it showed you why they they
banished him there because
he can't see time and space there he
can't see anything that's why he
couldn't see the ants coming
he can't see anything there he can't see
any timelines he can't see what's
branching what's happening she's what's
in front of him right so he's he's at
the mercy that's why he wants to get out
of there so bad and they knew by
banishing them here they can isolate him
um
and I think I think it's necessary for
the development of this character and
where they want to go with him I'm not I
like King a lot so I'm not so far
removed from the powers of King so I
know what he can do no I like the
Persona of King and I like the powers he
had I just would have preferred him to
leave a more dominant in this movie
that's all we got a two dollar sweepers
from Hollywood rules I also think we
were spoiled by Infinity warning game
that's that's my point I feel like we
are at a point with the MCU where it's
like yo like this is some of the best
like that part at the end of end game
where they did the the the the the the
portals opening all the Avengers
Assemble to me that's the greatest
moment in cinema history yeah like that
that is years and years of build up that
that that's one of the greatest moments
it was a nice build up
and the only way you got on your left
is if you watch Captain America and you
understood where him and Falcon was with
it
and he was just running past Falcon when
he was run it was when it was jogging in
the park and he was like on your left
so those little things
those little breadcrumbs that led you
all the way up to hair
we're getting little breadcrumbs we
don't know what bread crumbs we're
getting uh that's going to be call backs
when we do get a chance to see Kang
Dynasty and uh the secret Wars
those movies is are going to be
cumulations of all these other movies
building up to those big epic spots
we're still in the build-up phase nobody
said anything when you know Iron Man was
fighting Whiplash talking about oh that
that was new like see now we have
experience in the past where like
in a way it seemed like you know we
don't want to be patient because we was
patient then but that's not how movies
that's how like build up works so you
just want us we we want to just get to
the dessert yeah that's not how buildup
works though they they gotta have they
got they gotta sprinkle it to you man
they they gotta season the meat they
can't just give you the meat like yeah
pause
[Music]
just giving out raw meat
oh
you did you did that huh I'm just here
for the comedy really
yo that was all you we gonna clip that
part that's gonna be on the tick tock
like uh we gotta get to it let's get off
non-spoiler so we're done with the
spoilers right what we thinking about
popcorn man
three for me three popcorn because they
did Basics what what I expect
introduced three characters
establish uh a hierarchy and and a
pathway and where we're going they gave
you two end credit scenes
um
and they established where you're going
to go next the next place that you're
going to go you're going to go to uh
Loki right you're gonna go watch the
series of Loki so if you didn't watch
last uh series of Loki you're gonna go
watch that to understand exactly who's
King and he who remains
you have to see this uh so
they did the stuff that was necessary
did they go above and beyond did they
blow me away uh no they didn't uh I
expect them
and this is putting a lot of weight on
Guardians of the Galaxy
but with Guardians of the Galaxy
I expect a hell of a lot being James
Gunn's last film
uh being a couple of these characters
probably last screen time
you know I expect a lot so yeah going
into the future I feel that they're fun
they did what they were supposed to do
this movie gets a three popcorn for me I
would have loved to have given it a four
and a five but the substance and the the
potholes were just too much for me to
ignore
I give it a three two
um you know it's like I said the only
big thing I have an issue with is how
they handled King in certain aspects I
like his character I just wanted to see
more of the reason everyone fears him
you know what I'm saying like and they
don't know they fear him yet
well but I get that but when what's her
name was saying the whole time we can't
stop him we can't be stopped like like
and then I guess maybe it's because I'm
coming from the outside looking in and
people telling me what to expect but I'm
not seeing that on the screen but
all right so the fact that he dominated
and conquered and oppressed the whole a
small section of the quantum verse right
because that's a small section of the
quantum burst that he dominated and
subjugated right and we didn't get a
chance to see what he did to become that
dystopian King
now
when she got a chance to touch the
machine when she was turning it on she
got a chance to see his atrocities and
the things and stuff that he committed
throughout all his timelines as he was
going on becoming King the Conqueror and
she got a chance to see exactly how
horrific and how brutal and how maniacal
this guy is
that's where her fear lies I think that
what they could have did to win me over
a little bit more is like maybe have
like instead of showing a bunch show
like one detailed scene where he was
just so powerful no one can mess with
him you know what I'm saying that way
because that was my thing is people
saying this is going to be the next
Thanos this is the main bad guy for this
Saga I'm thinking in this movie I'm like
oh King about to mess up everyone like
it's not going to be the fight about
this too Thanos without those Infinity
Stones was not beating Avengers
I feel you
was not you you just saw him get Molly
walked all over the place if he did not
have those Infinity Stones he had the
Infinity Stones that gave him the leg up
they gave him the ability to fight all
these Heroes at one time and that was a
build up to that point because when he
was sitting in the chair floating in the
sky talking to Loki he did not know the
capabilities of this uh this character
at all so I mean and then when you got a
chance to see him fight the Hulk he was
like oh well he's that guy hmm so just
to clarify
the one at the inner Loki that was the
strongest one because he won no he's
just the one that remains
but he was the smartest one
oh my God I'm so confused he was the
smartest King see it's not about
strength with Kane it's about how he can
manipulate you out of your position
I mean he has all the Weaponry that he
can pull back and he can he can use but
to outsmart and to to kill the other
kings you have to be smarter then
right and and they're all smart relating
yeah well they all the same person
there's just certain experiences made
some of them more unique than others
yeah I feel you and that's like I said
I'm not
I'm not [__] on Kang I just wanted
to see more dominant
Kane then I wanted like when he when he
was in that room like I said he threw
Ant-Man and homegirl against the wall I
wanted to see that in a bigger way in
the end you know what I'm saying where
oh and it's like the suit was damaged I
get that but that's not my fault like
right but when I thought my fault the
scriptwriters decided it was a good idea
to break the the lead honcho suit and
the first time you really see him do
anything how are you going to stop him
you have to be able but could we could
we agree that they could he could have
had his own little thing going on then
maybe break his suit not break his suit
off the bat walk on the field breaks his
suit that doesn't do anything walks on
the field defends himself with a barrier
then break his suit you know you're
gonna have a lot of people coming to
hate you that's fine it'll come for you
because that's pure cap he was doing a
whole bunch of stuff up until that point
and yeah you thousand-year-old ants
coming in yeah you know what he was
doing come all King you know what he was
doing he was ordering other people to do
something else
yo put the put the guns on shoot don't
let him come this far like that's what
he was doing like yeah and he was just
like he
his uh biggest his biggest asset is to
be able to predict the future in the
timelines to know exactly what's going
to happen
that's his biggest asset if I remember
correctly in the Loki show
he said he knew everything up to a
certain point and then he's like I don't
know anything after this after this
point I don't know
he said yeah you killed me be careful
same thing with the movie so you're
pretty much saying that
because there's a character in Bleach uh
that they brought back the new anime
that's kind of similar he could see a
certain amount of into the future now
obviously it's different type of powers
but
um you're saying that he's pretty much
in there in the like his key component
he doesn't have it's like Thor fighting
about him he's fighting with one hand
behind his back it's like Thor fighting
without the hammer yeah
okay I feel you on that you know maybe I
need to see more of Kang not being
restrained if if
if you listen to them
he said I killed so many Avengers
so many of them that's cool but that was
done off screen fam I don't care
you say what you want uh first off he
was with a bunch of other kings that's
why they that's why they got you up out
of there how do I know they like 15 of
you didn't jump one Thor like I gotta
see it to believe it and I didn't see it
I don't believe it
just wait until it all unfolds and for
the love of God stop listening to the
so-called leakage of the people who
swear they know him I don't I don't
actually keep up at least in the in the
movies we don't do that
um and anything we do we might talk
about like rumors like castings or you
know we might talk about leaks going on
for because that that's that's content
like here's the thing people clown on
people for talking like in the gaming
industry in the movie industry why are
you talking about leaks
that's their job
it's it's to talk about the latest stuff
that's going on in the industry
and give their opinion on if they think
it's a good idea or not if it happens
now I think you're more referring to
like the Jeff grubs over there where
they're actually saying this isn't what
I think is good or bad this is what's
happening I think you're referring to
more like the Insiders in the movie
industry uh but you know I'm not
referring to them really that oh that
was that wasn't Kane at his weakest I'm
I'm gonna beg to differ that wasn't king
of his weakness the weakest uh Trust
Tang had his Tech it was there
and that he was not able to predict the
ants you saw the highest form of ants
you're ever going to see right
ants with tech that evolved it thousands
of years
when you see the movie you understand
that the answer is very formidable he's
a formidable ants my only problem is
why the hell is an Ant-Man controlling
the ants why is Hank Pym controlling the
answer oh because he's Ant-Man so why
the hell do we have Scott Lang
I'm just saying
I feel you well that's pretty much all I
got for for this man it's like I said
um
maybe I just had like unrealist
expectations to how he was actually
gonna pull things off and it has nothing
to do with like Kane or you know Ant-Man
I don't really know Ant-Man is like the
controlling person that controls ants
and I think that's what infuriates you
because I don't watch comics and the
whole thing I didn't even know he
controlled ants to you said it on the
show so
and I think that's that's the issue you
have
he flying on the back of Lance he was
able I'm just because I remember they
did a little bit of that in the first
Ant-Man that's it just so this is his
name it's not because he gets smaller
size of ants no he controls ants I
thought they caught
I thought they called him Ant-Man
because he gets small to the size of an
aunt not because he could chose no man
listen he gets small he flies on the
back of ants wasp has the the wasp sting
and she has the wings
this you're going to a Time
when making characters
were they talked about the ability oh he
crawls the wall he shoot webs Spider-Man
not that hard
oh he he shrinks and he controls ants
Ant-Man not that hard Paris got you he
said well Spider-Man does not have
anything to do with spiders well he he
kind of like that's not entirely true
his abilities originate from spiders
like being able to like stick itself to
the wall I don't know if that's exactly
how it went watch the Spidey verse and
there are Spiderman that actually
control spiders
I forgot I haven't watched that in a
minute stop and you know it stop it
I think that might have been directed
towards me too because I said his his
name
was because he can get the size of Aunt
so and Batman doesn't control bats yes
he does
he doesn't have any powers but he does
have machines where he actually can have
bats remember he had all the bats
swirling around him stuff like that as
he hit in the bat cave even though he's
uh battle phobic or something like that
just saying uh just saying in the MCU oh
yeah I fail you I I just think that when
it comes to this they just gotta do
better that's all like you know tighten
up on the script writing you know I I
didn't really see too much of anything
that was like done for any well you know
reasons and so I I think that the movie
was a solid movie it's just I I honestly
do feel like you know this has been one
of the worst MCU movies in a while thank
you and you know and what's funny is the
reason I call it a solid movie is
because no one else is making anything
remotely good these days like the MCU is
probably single-handedly keeping the
movie industry up right now the the
theater industry up right now
listen
a stinky movie
Is Not Gonna Save the box office this is
a stinky movie I don't think it's going
to do very well
you know what's crazy you know it's
crazy
I thought Black Adam was better than
this
I can't go that far I think this movie
was better than Black Adam you thought
this this movie was better than Black
Adam yeah I I didn't like Black Adam oh
I did
I throw Black Adam because I'm a huge
fan of the character and I thought the
rock pulled it off
I just I think somebody manipulated the
numbers
I think somebody manipulated the numbers
to get them out of there because I I
don't know I don't I didn't have as much
thanks about that movie then I do have
this but um listen we have a ton of
movies coming this year uh someone said
uh talk about uh talk on Maverick was
good I didn't see Avatar but it's making
money I'm not saying that the Marvel
things are the only things keep in the
movie theaters up but let's be real here
like up until this year it's been hit
and miss every year like uh you know
what like and just think about that how
many people in this chat went to the
movies to see a non-marvel movie it
doesn't happen often I'm not saying it
doesn't happen get the game pass but it
doesn't happen at all you can do it
and hopefully we get sponsored by them
hey Regal so what's going on King what
what what's what's what you doing this
week okay well I don't know I gotta pull
up this app I'm gonna see another movie
that we can go check out on Friday uh
I'll let you know exactly what we'll be
talking about next week because I know
the week after that we'll be talking
about Creed Three so Creed 3 comes out
on three three make me go watch a boxing
movie yes I am gonna make you go watch a
boxing movie you know why guess who's
playing in it King the Conqueror
Jonathan Majors this is inside uh
hopefully he'll be more dominant in that
movie then yeah apparently he looks
crazy dominant he looks like uh what's
this guy um Club elang he looks like
Creed's Club elang in this film
I can't wait and that's Mr T uh if you
didn't know who Club Elaine was
I can't wait for this film I thought
this film was going to be exactly what
it is
it looks fire I cannot wait to see this
and then after seeing how Jonathan
Majors moved on Scott Lang he was yo
that uppercut that he threw that he had
with it was like he teleported it
he was definitely dominating him he was
beaten ill if if
the WASP doesn't show up
the Watts don't show up Scott don't make
it out of there live He's stomping his
helmet off yo I'm not gonna lie I I
can't wait to see this movie Creed Three
um and I gotta go through the list attic
and I have a ton of movies so every week
we'll be doing some spoiler stuff like
this but we uh we're gonna have to give
you two episodes of The Last of Us uh
next week and if you're going to the
patreon check out the patreon uh attic
is doing chainsaw man he's finishing up
chainsaw man and I'm finishing up season
one of Attack on Titan going into season
two he said I'm right at his best
episode so
um
hopefully it it blows me away because
Ant-Man quantumania didn't so it is what
it is what's up with you there is the
patreon so definitely go there sub to
that we got a five dollar tier where you
can ask any question uh we're about to
get to the questions uh of this one and
normally we do it at the beginning but I
wanted to do it at the end because
there's only two questions I don't want
to like ruin the flow of the actual
podcast you said Creed is technically
fighting King in another timeline
that's a barrier
all right so
we have this question it is from King of
Kings do you think people are being too
harsh on Marvel phase four and the start
of phase five do you think fans are
setting uh setting their expectations
too high expecting in-game Infinity War
level for every Marvel movie that has
come out since in game by the way the
new Ant-Man movie was awesome and
enjoyed from start to finish okay well I
mean if he enjoyed it and there's no way
in hell I can take away your joy if if
you go to it as a this is the problem
with me being a comic book nerd
all right I can't go in there and say
all the knowledge that I have in my head
like oh let me push it to the side I
can't do it um so you know when I go in
there and I watch it with my son or I
watch it with my wife uh I get a chance
to see it through their eyes and get a
chance to hear the stuff from them but
if I have disappointment and stuff I'm
gonna have disappointment and stuff so
yeah
um
that's that's how I feel about it what
about you about it
um I do have the the questions for this
week up on the screen I think
it's like I said I do think we have a
lot of that going on people are
comparing this to the to the to the
climax of the of the infinity stone Saga
and I think you have a lot of people
expecting every movie to be around that
level and that's just not that's not
realistic they build up to it it wasn't
that for me it was 20 some movies built
up to it wasn't it yeah but you got to
remember you got to look at uh Thor the
Dark World throw it away uh you got to
look at Captain America the first one
um oh God another uh boar film uh you
have to look at a lot of these films
that wasn't hitting for a lot of people
like some people didn't like Captain
Marvel
um so again you know it's it's all about
your choice and and who you choose to
like and what you choose to like from it
then we got dipped down games in anime
uh what were you feeling towards Modoc
uh have we seen the last of them I
personally could not wait for him to be
off screen to be off-screen he was
killing my vibe Jonathan Majors was a
standout keep up the attack on Titan and
Chainsaw reacts
okay
um Moto I was happy that they didn't shy
away showed his little butt
yeah little arms and little legs and uh
big ass head uh I'm Happy
from it uh I'm happy that they did a
comic book accurate Modoc
and
you know hopefully hopefully we get a
chance to see him again as they wipe his
mind and he's able to beat a motor that
we want and not Darren you know because
the whole Darren thing was that was
blowing me like you know I thought you
know oh Darren you know and he wouldn't
he wouldn't answer them until he said
Murdock and he's like yeah yeah see
that's it I felt like his you know we're
not getting into it yeah
yeah he said Dark World was great
[Laughter]
I don't ever want to talk to you again
sir
Dark World almost sunk the Thor
franchise you better thank Tyson watiti
for uh for coming out and giving you
Thor Ragnarok
so you know I mean when it comes down to
it uh it is what it is uh I actually
think Modoc was done horribly but I
think his character development was bad
I think his visualization off of what
I've seen on the the videos that I
looked up for him that was pretty good
off of what I would have expected him to
look like off those videos but as far as
like his character development I thought
it was gone awful but yo they got him
spot on with the big ass head though
oh that was crazy you're ridiculous but
that's pretty much the whole show guys
uh you know follow us on your Twitter uh
uh Lord addict IOP King David
WTF I think that's yours no OTW OTW and
everybody don't understand they think
it's on the way no it's of the world
stupid
uh we will be reacting to the state of
play on Thursday I think it's Thursday
the 23rd yes sir tomorrow's the attic
show man I'm gonna be doing some every
day on streams this week
um I'll be on Boom show tomorrow at 7 pm
so I'll be there for like an hour
but I'm pretty sure for coming through
you know we we enjoy these these things
man that's why we started this because
uh I for one actually enjoy talking
about something that's not gaming now uh
yeah I actually look forward to the
rnr's not that I don't look forward to
iron Lord's podcast but it's nice to
talk about something that I haven't
talked about for like five years
uh appreciate all the people coming in
the chat you know uh flame uh Paris
Lockhart you know definitely coming in
here and uh telling me that I had the
wrong expectations for uh for king
that's perfectly fine
that's crazy
every couple through we're gonna go
ahead and pull out of here these will be
up on the r r Channel probably tomorrow
definitely like I said go sub to the
patreon we got plenty of reactions for
you guys King's reacting to attack on
Titan right now and I'm reacting to
chainsaw man uh last week I didn't post
anything because we had a lot of stuff
going on with the real with stuff but
I'm going to start posting yeah I'm
going to start posting because I got
like seven eight
eight videos in the top
it's crazy but also
um what else what else we have we have
um the road to packs hey guys all all
the um everything that you contribute to
here to over at iron Lords um that helps
us go into the road to packs so yeah
thank you so much
and you'll definitely go on there you
know in our description you know I'm
just saying you know sign up for you a
honey account you know I'm just saying
I'm just saying you know
um